this wood was going to be thrown away
now John Nelson Fernandez is using his
carpentry skills to make it into a
cupboard nine months ago he was
struggling with alcoholism then he came
for help at El Shaddai tents a rehab
center in southern Cape Verde now he
works from dawn till dusk seven days a
week the cupboard is a gift for his
mother Ella Miyagi delete a video
bastante minty bastante concealing she
helped me very much she told me to stop
drinking alcohol to overcome this
addiction Ella me up or would she
supported me a lot and it drives me it
was just okay now that I'm here in this
rehab center I think she'll be very
happy with what I'm doing for her yet
with the finish Connie's used it for
their prayer when he was younger general
Tsin dreamt of being a lawyer but at the
age of 19 he started drinking later
things got out of hand
John Olsen punched his brother and was
ordered to pay a fine he couldn't afford
he then started drinking heavily and
spent all his money on alcohol estaba me
Mort porky the fish bank I'd spank guy
to protect I was half dead because I was
beaten up by thugs two or three times it
was I almost died
the era Demaret I was hospitalized and
in a coma are you okay and I just
thought about my daughter because I love
her very much I think about her all the
time
darah at El Shaddai tents there are
strict rules all 40 residents of the
center are woken up at 6:30 in the
morning
after morning prayers and breakfast they
start work there's bread to be baked and
some at the rehab center work on the
organic farm which provides food for the
residents whatever is left is sold in a
nearby village the profits come back to
the rehab center inori off regatta
founded it in 1996 the 68 year old says
there's a lot more work to be done
[Music]
well my audience appears always what's
the main cause of death in Cape Verde's
alcoholism what's the number-one cause
of car accidents alcoholism what's
behind gender-based violence and broken
families alcoholism alcoholism more than
three thousand people have passed
through the center since it was founded
but now it has hit hard times at the
moment it's difficult to pay electricity
water and food bills many patients stay
here after their recovery because they
can't find a job Johnny Olsen Fernandez
is among those struggling to leave al
Shaddai he hasn't given up hope of
making a living through carpentry to
take care of his family